et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
alexis corbière bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous déborder la
france insoumise de la seine saint denis
en détention pendant 20 minutes pour des
interviews en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
baptiste biz la nouvelle république on a
le plaisir d'accueillir jean baptiste
jour orione merci d'être avec nous on
commence à alexis corbière par la
nouvelle loi anti terroriste les députés
ont commencé à examiner hier après midi
c'est une loi qui renforce les moyens de
renseignement pour prévenir les actes
terroristes et qui renforce aussi le
contrôle des condamnés pour terrorisme
à leur sortie de prison pourquoi vous
opposez à ce texte parce que vous dit
gentiment la nouvelle loi
de fait c'est une nouvelle loi mais
franchement c'est la roue production de
textes de la logique de précédents
textes en année à 36 texte je crois en
35 ans qui concerne 25 depuis 1986 oui
mesdames les médias entre lui les voix
sur la délinquance les lois sur le
terrorisme qui sont toujours la même
philosophie la restriction des libertés
nous on aimerait connaît une discussion
une réflexion termes de stratégie de
lutte contre le terrorisme contre ce
terrorisme islamiste en particulier mais
sur le terrorisme en général y en a
parfois l'impression qu'il ya une
surenchère verbale au nom du fait qu'il
faut agir pour en quelque sorte envoyer
des messages à nos concitoyens ont
s'agit on restreint des libertés ont
créé en généralistes des choses pendant
les visites domiciliaires je l'évoqué
hier sur les 149 visite domiciliaire qui
ont lieu depuis trois ans en 48 n'ont
absolument servi à rien et là selon elle
a été utile sans doute que du
renseignement du bon vieux
renseignements l'ancien aurait été tout
aussi efficace
donc on nomme pas assez de moyens à ce
qui est utile dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme notamment des moyens humains
par exemple ont déjà eu des moyens
dominé nanterre pour le renseignement
intérieur notamment sur la plateforme
pharos c'était l'objet d'une grande dune
gros de grands désaccords à l'époque
avec le ministre darmanin ya peu de
temps ou même ses prédécesseurs on a été
un peu entendu parce que nous pensons
que c'est ce type de dispositif qu'il
faut aider ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui dia dispositif législatif
qui existe auxquels il faut donner des
moyens humains qu'il faut évaluer
évaluer c'est aussi la faiblesse de ce
texte
est-ce qu'on peut évaluer ce qui a été
adopté il ya encore moins - donnant et
on est parfois dans les tests qui se
superposent et qui ont assez peu
d'efficacité de ces sections et qui
amène j'ai et je trouve que c'est pour
ça que c'est très politique mais
politiciens on sentait gative du mot ce
que fait le gouvernement c'est que sitôt
que nous faisons des critiques on a eu
du pot moretti qui est arrivé qui nous a
dit qu'en gros on était du côté des
assassins des islamistes moi je trouve
que quand il était avocat c'était
acquittator depuis chemnitz et insultes
à tort franchement il fait que ça il est
assez grossier je lui ai dit hier le
style c'est l'homme dit-on c'était
buffon qui dit ça le sien est
reconnaissable
franchement c'est assez vulgaire sitôt
qu'on le critique c'est sa majesté a
toujours raison et sitôt que critique on
est du côté des assassins on est anti
flics ça c'est surtout darmana qui fait
ça on est du côté maintenant des
terroristes islamistes fa c'est
insupportable et quand on aime le
parlement et je lui dis en plus parce
qu'il faut défendre le parlement je me
dis à plusieurs titres et je repassage
rappelle que ma collègue bénédicte toto
riina encore parce que comme des
et à la révolte des paysans il s'est
fait secouer et brutalisé mais quand on
aime le parlement et koné ministre
mais quand on a une opposition face à
soi on la respecte on essaie d'écouter
ou sans les critiques et on ramène pas
ce qu'on me dise et des arguments
tellement simple qui ne s'adresse qu'à
des esprits simplistes à savoir si vous
me critiquer mon texte
si vous voulez un bilan des 35 lois
antiterroristes et compta délinquance de
ces dernières années c'est exact du côté
de ceux qui gobent nos concitoyens
franchement c'est vulgaire et insultant
on va y revenir sur le fond de cette
affaire vous concrètement vous proposez
quoi quand même pour répondre c'est la
menace terroriste qui équipe permanente
parce que nous disons oui john deux
outils supplémentaires renforcé
renforcer nos services de renseignements
c'est assez important
c'est ça qui est déterminant vous savez
c'est l'information tous ces algorithmes
aujourd'hui quand nous proposons assez
peu d'efficacité
d'autant qu'ils sont mis entre
man aussi de différentes agences qui
sont liées aux états unis et qui sont
liées notamment à la cia donc tout ça
mais pour vous ça suffit le
renseignement humain notamment sur son
appel les signaux faibles
il n'y a pas besoin de delgo rythme et
de plus d'efficacité
mais c'est assez peu efficace justement
ce que je demande c'est qu'on évalue ce
qui a d'ores et déjà été mis en place
est ce que le second s'aperçoit c'est
que les différents attentats des mamans
qui ont été déjoués les visites
domiciliaires que j'évoquais je crois
qu'il ya eu là aussi sur les 58 ou 59
attentats qui ont été déjoués
franchement dans l'ultra grande majorité
des cas 58 3 c'est du service de
renseignement qui a permis de les
déjouer donc donnons les moyens ce que
ça ait du recrutons des gens recrutés
encore plus le les deux mines déjà
recruté lui sans aucun doute et
donneront aussi des moyens travail et
vous savez la vie viennent d'arriver les
2000 essayons de voir qu'est-ce que ça
produit vert et talent mais surtout ne
resterez n'ont pas nos libertés
publiques je sais bien nos concitoyens à
juste raison sont inquiets de la
situation mais c'est pas en créant une
gigantesque loi des suspects un qu'on va
régler le problème et moi c'est pourquoi
j'ai trouvé que même le texte on n'a
plus le temps de développer mais ce
qu'on appelait séparatisme renforcement
des cervidés des principes républicains
était plus un texte comment dirais-je
pour blessée humiliée nos concitoyens de
confession musulmane sans aucune
efficacité contre le terrorisme qui vise
à s'introduire situation culturelle
alors que l'esprit même de 1905 la
laïcité c'est que précisément il ya une
stricte séparation entre l'état et et le
et le cultuel mais on veut faire croire
que comme ça on va être plus efficaces
mais là vous avez employé l'expression
de loi des suspects pour vous cette loi
c'est une loi des sujets mauvais c'est
une loi des suspects allaient assez peu
efficace elle-même parce qu'elle crée le
sentiment que même que l'on va on va
surveiller les gens qu'on va pouvoir
débarquer à toute heure et qu'on va
mettre tout le monde dans une situation
de contrôle généralisé de ceux qui font
alors que tout ça est notamment à
travers des algorithmes et sur les
raisons alors que tout ça est assez peu
efficace
par contre recrutons des gens pourquoi
pas même on aura compris des locuteurs
particulier puisqu'on a à faire des fois
de terrorisme islamiste qui comprennent
mieux ce qui se passe ça c'est efficace
et souvent pourquoi on s'est affaibli
par rapport à ça c'est connu des
politiques publiques en raison des
politiques d'austérité qui enfilait le
service public dont services de police
et de renseignement
de votre point de vue est ce que ce
texte menace l'état de droit ben tu peux
oui parce que effectivement il
il restreint des libertés mais je veux
prendre un exemple sur ce que je veux
dire tout près de cinq ans comme me
comprenne bien et je lui ai dit hier au
ministre garde des sceaux dernièrement
une des personnes qui a attaqué au
couteau je crois que c'était rambouillet
est quelqu'un qui a de trouver sérieux
troubles psychiatriques est quelqu'un
qui est allé en prison qui s'est
radicalisée en prison c'est à dire qui
est allé en prison pour des faits
délictueux qui n'était pas lié au fait
qu'il était islamistes et au sein de la
prison
il s'est radicalisé et à sa sortie de
prison n'ayant pas été suivies sur plan
psychiatrique et s'étend radicaliser
qu'il est il à nouveau frappé avec en
faisant cet acte odieux que nous
condamnons tous ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'on pourra aussi s'interroger
sur le fait que et ça a été constaté par
nombre de rapports parlementaires que la
prison aujourd'hui tel quel et accueille
déjà 30% de personnes 25 % de personnes
qui sont au coeur des troubles
psychiatriques qui n'ont rien à faire en
prison qu'il faudrait traiter à part je
dis pas les mettre en liberté ceux qui
nous suivent ne tombe pas dans le
panneau qui consiste à dire on va les
mettre dehors mais traitées dans des
structures particulières pour que le
trou particulier qui subissent soit pris
en charge et que l inverse aussi la
prison soit pas un lieu de
radicalisation ou des gens qui n'ont pas
qui ne sont pas liées jusqu'à présent à
une religion de manière exalté
dangereuse en sorte de là ça aussi ce
serait efficace
on peut en discuter de ça la prison est
quelque part un lieu de radicalisation
on travaille à saint didace et ça nous
intéresse intéresse la société pour
vidanger déjà près de 200 condamnés pour
terrorisme qui vont sortir de prison et
c'est aussi l'objet de ce texte est de
renforcer le suivi de ces personnes là
est ce que là vous êtes d'accord qu'il
faut le renforcer le suivi de ces
personnes qui sortent ils ont ce suivi
existent d'ores et déjà et par ailleurs
l'idée aussi comme ne faut pas le
renforcer ben pas particulièrement où il
d'ores et déjà vous savez c'est pas des
gens qui vont se balader librement qu'on
va pas surveiller ça c'est mes autres au
delà tous savent bien sûr qu'il faut
continuer avait à veiller à ce qu'ils
font et éventuellement veiller à ce
client contrôle judiciaire dans le cadre
de l'état de droit
vous savez quand on a été condamné pour
terrorisme mais bien le renseignement
continuent à suivre ce que vous faites
sur ceux actuels ça prolonge leur durée
ça les renforts ces mesures un homme
vous allez le voter mais non mais non on
est contre ce texte vous l'avez vous ne
verrez rien on va voir le débat tel
qu'il est nous on porte des amendements
notamment par les services humains de
renseignements mais j'ai tel que la
tournure qu'a pris le débat vous avez
raison qu'il faut jamais cantonnée
parlementaire préjugés même si on a un
désaccord de fond mais la manière dont
le débat a été posée hier on a bien vu
qui est un peu au burin j'ai envie de
bien bons notamment sur ce point vous
avez entendu eric dupond-moretti vous
étiez présent dans l'hémicycle hier il a
dit accepter il vous a dit à vous la
france est soumise à accepter que des
gens qui sont encore dangereuse
promènent en liberté
c'est irresponsable et indigne je le
laisse à ses propos moi ce qui me sidère
c'est que ces gens qui font la leçon
sont en responsabilité que ce soit la
droite ou le gouverneur actuel depuis
des années mais viennent accuser encore
la france insoumises du fait qu'en
quelques sanctions nous responsables de
la situation
aucune modestie de leur part pour quelle
raison par exemple sur le sujet dans
tito remy encore des gens qui continuent
à frapper notamment des policiers
pourquoi des gens qui ont gvt auquel ce
cas de quelqu'un qui est un trouble
psychiatrique
on pourrait continuer surprendre les
violences faites aux femmes qui étaient
soi-disant le grand sujet que monsieur
le garde des sceaux aussi devrait nous
aider on peut regarder le nombre de cas
de gens qui ne sont pas suivis qui ont
frappé leur femme que le leurs épouses
hélas souvent désormais décédés est
allée au commissariat mais la justice
n'a pas suivi la police n'a pas eu les
moyens
ces gens là n'ont jeu là je parle pour
le coup de l'arrogance avec lequel
monsieur dupont et il s'adresse à nous
ne tire aucun bilan de leurs faiblesses
qui par leurs faiblesses personnelles
mais souvent des politiques conséquent
des politiques qui mènent et nous met
encore sur les genoux la responsabilité
des problèmes donc tout le monde voit
bien que ces politiciens toussaint
totalement politicien c'est des textes
d'agitation ces textes sont pas
d'efficacité c'est des textes de cache
misère en vérité souvent des conditions
de travail difficiles un tel travail de
renseignement et escaut comme je le
disais sur tout mais on va peut-être
arrêter sur cette séquence et que juste
parce que la chose soit claire pas ce
que je vais dire à la tribune et jeu que
la formule soit clair un acte terroriste
c'est pas s'il ya une différence avec ce
qui est un acte criminel
c'est qu'il a une volonté politique
c'est à dire de mettre une société sous
tension d'amener à ce que notamment les
dispositifs légistatives la société
évolue donc prônons
parfois c'est nécessaire de faire
évoluer la loi mais nous mêmes de ne pas
accepter l'agenda que nous fixent les
terroristes en quelque sorte en créant
une situation qui vise à souvent
notamment montré une partie de nos
concitoyens comme étant des suspects a
priori la gv opus la loi que sur
laquelle j'avais beaucoup travaillé sur
séparatisme que j'ai évoqués c'est que
les associations cultuelles d'un certain
culte sont surveillés alors que tout
démontre qu'en vérité ça n'est pas un
autre sujet avec baptiste de les saisir
le conseil constitutionnel sur cette
l'antiterroriste oui c'est ugo
bernalicis qui s'occupe de ça on va
saisir parce qu'on pense que nombre de
libertés publiques sont mis en cause on
a parlé du tour de france et de la
république entame aujourd'hui son tour
de france par le lot son tour de france
des régions qui va le conduire tout
l'été dans dix départements fin dans dix
régions celui d'une bonne chance de voir
un président république sur le terrain à
la rencontre des habitants vous avez
approuvé j'imagine oui moi c'est la
stratégie du grand râteau là pour les
élections qui viennent alors il va comme
ça passe et de comment nearly c'est le
territoire national bon non mais comme
président de la république mois après je
suis un comment dire à quelqu'un qui
critiquent la la la fonction
présidentielle qui est très présidentiel
en scène camille république donc c'est
un peu sa majesté va voir ces sujets ou
bon mais l'idée qu'il aille sur le
terrain moi je vais pas la critique et
par contre acceptons l'idée qu'il en
campagne présidentielle voilà ce qui est
en train de faire c'est le candidat pour
vous puisque le président qu'ils et
voilà qu'ils se déplacent pour voir quoi
souvent ce qu'il sait déjà j'espère mais
il va toucher des mains et il pense que
le contact c'est un homme qui a le
contact facile on peut lui reprocher
beaucoup de choses mais il est plutôt si
on lui reproche à la firme a dit lisant
ce qui honnêtement un service je sais
pas ce que vous en avez parler mais
d'une démagogie effrayante affalage ou
bref il se perd mais c'est la même chose
on s'adresse aux jeunes avec ses 2 you
tube heures ou au passage on rigole sur
le cannabis à usage de la drogue tout en
expliquant que c'est très grave le
cannabis à usage de la drogue chacun à
mon avis se perd dans tout ça la
désormais ils vivent en province pour
voir ce qui se passe bon ce qu'est ce
qui va rencontrer sans doute j'espère
qu'ils les verras c'est le fait qu'il ya
des millions de gens qui sont sous le
seuil de pauvreté actuellement c'est le
fait qu'à partir du 1er juin
la réforme d'assurance chômage amène à
ce qu'on va faire 2,3 milliards d'euros
d'économies sur le roi des sur les
droits des chômeurs qui a une vague
la quatrième vague commente g10 sociale
qui arrive c'est à dire il ya 400 plan
social et qui sont en place dans le pays
avec beaucoup d'entreprises qui parfois
certaines ayant bénéficié des aides
publiques mal ciblés on en parlera
peut-être mais avec des groupes qui font
du profit et qui dit 106 j'espère qu'il
va voir tout ça pas seulement des
acteurs de l air eux mêmes comme c'est
parfois le cas des militants qui vont
crier macro macron sur son passage bon
on regardera les images attentivement
mais ils nous ont déjà fait le coup vous
savez un d'une mise en scène comme ça
ils avaient qu on appelle ça le truc
potemkine quoi c'est à dire qu'on fit
visiter des fausses du sinn avec la
fumée qui sort des cheminées alors qui a
rien derrière
là c'est parfois le cas come back on se
promène ya que des gens enthousiastes
vive manu et puis en vérité les
militants sont mis au loin les crs
bloquent etc
on observera tout ça on va parler d elle
puisqu' on va parler du budget
rectificatif qui est présenté ce matin
m'a dit effectivement le gouvernement
présente ce matin en conseil des
ministres un budget rectificatif de 15
milliards de mesures d'urgence pour les
secteurs les plus en difficulté ça on
imagine que vous allez l'a prouvé que
vous allez voter ce budget non mais aidé
des entreprises bon il faut le faire le
global mans comme ce qui se passe après
vous allez être dégressif parce qu'il ya
en effet leur le sur tout ce qui est en
train d'être mis en place et que
progressivement c'est que
progressivement les aides vont commencer
à baisser
d'accord surtout moi ce que je
regrettais là où le gouvernement a mené
une mauvaise politique et à gaspiller
l'argent public c'est ce que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure c'est que dans les aides
publiques qui ont été accordés aux
entreprises ça n'était pas ciblé on a un
tissu économique qui a besoin d'être tpe
pme indiscutablement il faut continuer à
les aider et je regrette que là ça
commence à baisser les aides alors mais
lloris est pour vous mais il ya un
gaspillage d'argent public sur lequel
notamment toutes les entreprises qui ont
touché des aides publiques qui ont fait
des profits et qui licencient devrait
rendre l'argent c'est ça que devrait
exiger ce budget et dispositif qui
devrait être mis en place
est il normal qu'en période de crise du
comité commun de rencontrer les sommes
reversées aux actionnaires les
dividendes versés aux actionnaires de la
porno
nos grandes entreprises n'a jamais été
aussi important 51 milliards d'euros de
dividendes versés aux actionnaires nous
on a proposé une loi qui conti
profiteurs de crise pour le dire
simplement que toutes les entreprises
qui ont fait des surprofits en période
de crise se voit on peut rajouter les
choses qu on accepte que le maintiennent
leurs profits ont peu classique mais
tout ce qui est du surprofits en période
de crise soient redistribués vers ceux
qui nombreux motifs que ça n'ait pas
fait vous ne voterez pas de reste
oui sans doute parce qu'en fait je dis
c'est un texte d'affichage qui vise à
masquer en vérité le fait que les aides
pour les entreprises ont commencé à
baisser et qu'on a gaspillé des mêmes
qui mettent en place beaucoup d'argent
public qui serait nécessaire aujourd'hui
pour continuer à aider nos entreprises
et enfin ce que je veux moi c'est qu'on
est en place un dispositif
d'interdiction des licenciements dans
les entreprises qui font des profits
parce que vous savez ce qu'ils veulent
ce qui est en train d'avoir lieu c'est
des milliers de licenciements qui sont
en place et ça va coûter extrêmement
cher au pays sans compter toute une
série de mesures sociales je peux pas
oublier de vous dire que depuis hier
c'est le début des expulsions locatives
qui des possibilités qui voit là pardon
de le dire mieux que moi c'est soixante
mille familles qui sont concernées
moi je suis élue de seine-saint-denis
c'est ça que je vois c'est ça que je
vois je vois des patrons qui en peuvent
plus et qui ne sont pas assez aidé je
vois des gens qui subissent la précarité
je vois des gens qui bascule sous le
seuil de pauvreté je vois des familles
qui sont en situation difficile et qui
est ce que d'être expulsé voilà ce qui
m'inquiète un mot sur la pma le taxait
de retour à l'assemblée nationale là
aussi vous félicite emmanuel macron
aille au bout de sa promesse de l'apn
pour le coup et je souhaite et je
souhaite la suppression je crois des
modifications que les sénateurs ont fait
moi je suis favorable à la pma et quand
je dis je c'est l'ensemble de la france
cela me semble être un droit et qu'il
faut mettre en place et c'était une
promesse d' emmanuel macron il est temps
de faire un bond en avant de parler
politique avec mathis puisque vous
parliez de
de bénédicte toto riina c'est votre
chemise qui a été bousculée s'est
violemment par les forces de l'ordre
lors d'une manifestation hier jean luc
mélenchon il a interpellé jean castex
aux questions d'actualité la tuile
demande des excuses du gouvernement jean
cas c'est que vous a répondu que la
manifestation n'a fait l'objet d'aucune
déclaration que l'occupation et est
illégal que les policiers ont été
blessés et ont été hospitalisés et que
le procureur est saisi des faits est-ce
que c'est pas plutôt à la justice de
s'emparer de ce sujet qu'au gouvernement
non mais que la justice s'en saisissent
et une jeune mais que les choses soient
claires mais quand je dis ça je le dis
au sénat et en défendant les sénateurs
et les députés quelle que soit leur
couleur politique je dis bien de quelle
que soit leur couleur politique qui est
pas méprise l'immunité parlementaire ne
doit pas servir à ce que des actes
délictueux personnels soient protégés ce
serait scandaleux
là ce dont on parle bénédicte taurine si
elle va là c'est que c'est la
confédération paysanne c'est une élue de
l'ariège où il ya évidemment milieu
rural des aviculteurs etc et il amène à
vouloir de la confédération paysanne
occupent et un meuble une agence pour
l'emploi afin de faire pression pour
obtenir un dialogue avec le gouvernement
si elle y va c'est ans comme député
politiquement pour accompagner cette
occupation pacifique
immédiatement la police a débarqué moi
j'en veux pas directement aux policiers
des consignes qu'ils sont et c'est assez
rapidement dégagé moi tout ça et
deuxièmement benedicto taurine portait
son écharpe d'élu et on voit les images
que vous avez montré le policier l'a
sort brutalement et même la frappe dans
le dos et l'a fait tomber
moi je dire il ce symbole d'une élue
pourtant les chats qui se fait frapper
par un policier brutalement rompu si
vous connaissez victorine c'est une amie
c'est pas un gros gabarit 1 je veux dire
le policier la frappe
je trouve moche je suis pas d'accord
c'est pas là c'est pas ma république moi
je suis pas d'accord et donc
l'interpellation caféière gens du clan
chant et de dire attention là ce climat
ça nous est déjà arrivé que des députés
se fasse verbalisé dans la sarre la
nation qui sont même pas insoumis que
notre collègue claude prudhomme a
bordeaux une fois aussi avec un coup de
matraque sur la tête etc etc
quand quelque sorte il ya des des
policiers qui n'ont pas comme on irait
je le rappelle que attention quand y'a
un parlementaire il est là sans doute
pour essayer de faciliter ou de chercher
le dialogue des lapereaux des raisons
politiques
ça va dire qu'il au dessus des lois mais
on doit quand même veiller à ce que le
sens politique de sa présence ne soit
pas comment dire je traitais à coups de
poings un coup de bousculade
c'est important pour défendre la
fonction parlementaire donc
dix amis qui m'écoutent et je défends
pas seulement victorine même si c'est
une amie c'est l'idée que quand même le
parlementaire c'est important c'est en
contre-pouvoir est par définition de le
pouvoir doit accepter que quand l'un on
peut entendre ce contre-pouvoir et là il
peut pas être bousculé on va parler des
régionales en ile-de-france baptiste oui
un nouveau sondage qui était publié hier
qui donne encore une fois valérie
pécresse largement en tête des
intentions de vote devant le candidat du
rassemblement national devant le
candidat de la république en marche et
tous les candidats de gauche sont en
retrait même audrey pulvar par repasse
sous la barre des 2 900 est ce que vous
n'avez pas l'impression maintenant à
quelques semaines du premier tour qui
sont tous en situation d'être éliminé en
tout cas que cette multiplication des
candidatures à gauche et éliminatoires
moi je vais enfin une lecture pourra
discuter d'autres régions positive de
phase positive déjà il faut toujours
aller vers la victoire et pas à cultiver
la morosité
ce que j'observe déjà parlons de la
candidate qui m'intéresse clémentine
autain qui est à 10% dans les sondages
c'est un joli score qui peut pourquoi
pas être en tête des listes de gauche
que vous évoquez au soir du premier tour
c'est le 20 juin faut s'organiser pour
aller voter
merci à public sénat de rappeler
l'importance de cette élection ceux qui
m'écoutent aller voter ce qu'ils peuvent
donner un coup de main pour être
assesseur on a besoin faudrait pas
qu'une des victimes du coup vite soit la
démocratie deuxièmement je reviens à mon
sujet oui clémentine autain peut être
pourquoi pas en tête de ces trois listes
de gauche nous nous sommes engagés nous
l'avons répété à ce que nous sommes
favorables à ce qu'elle fusionne et on
peut avoir un second tour très ouverts
en vérité où nous pouvons tous
rassemblés être à plus de 30% et
pourquoi pas aller battre madame valérie
pécresse
parce que je trouve qu'on parle beaucoup
de monsieur bardella moi j'essaie de
regarder les chiffres
la dernière fois monsieur valente
saint-just était à dix huit et demi
rassemblement national donc en a été
monsieur bardella qui a droit des titres
des foi de certains journaux expliquant
que le n progresse en ile-de-france il à
ce stade je ne sais pas ce qui sortira
des urnes et dans nos scores assez
classique de ce qu'est le rassemblement
national anciennement front national et
moi j'observe que au sein de des listes
écologistes ce que nous portons nous à
clémentine autain france insoumise et
nos amis communistes et le et le parti
socialiste
déjà il ya un effondrement du parti
socialiste ça c'est une caractéristique
politique qu'il faudra analyser la
candidate de madame hidalgo est au plus
mal
bon à faudra analyser ça mais ça peut ça
peut peut-être dire quelque chose
par rapport à d'autres débats et nous on
est ça veut dire quoi que ça va ça va
être un problème pour la candidature
j'écoutais audrey pulvar par ailleurs
que moi j'apprécie beaucoup et que
auquel j'apporte mon soutien notamment
encore dernièrement grande elle s'est
fait menacer intimider on va dire par
monsieur darmanin pour des propos qui
sont quand même on a le droit de tenir
les propos qu'elle avait tenus en disant
qu'elle avait vu des choses glaçante et
elle s'était fait menacé d'être traînés
en justice
mais bon là je dire allez sur un
toboggan donc et ça c'est quelque chose
qui est l'élément nouveau
je rappelle que monsieur bartolone qui
porte les couleurs du ps lors des
élections régionales était à 25%
cette fois-ci madame pulvar qui la
candidate madame hidalgo est à 9%
à bon entendeur salut peut-être que ça
veut dire quelque chose on analysera
après moi je me méfie de discuter trop
le départ s'est converti que vous nous
dites vous souhaitez le rassemblement
des livres et vous pensez que c'est
clémentine autain qui sera en test
je le souhaite je le souhaite si jamais
c'est julien bayou qui en tête avec le
moment c'est les yeux des sondeurs je la
veux dire vous rangerez clairement je
lui avait clairement clairement est
clairement non mais je veux dire on l'a
dit clairement
clémentine autain la répéter on
souhaitait même avec julien bayou
pourquoi pas discuté de listes communes
dès le premier tour c'est eux qui n'ont
pas voulu comme souvent nos amis
d'europe écologie les verts ne veulent
pas seulement que derrière le truc
singulis et qu'après il nous reproche à
nous soit disant la france soumise
d'être toujours mais eux ne bon bref
qu'importe là il ya un premier tour moi
je trouve ça pas inintéressant faut
observer vous faire campagne ont fait
campagne
d'ailleurs au passage on fera sans doute
un meeting le 13 juin à montreuil avec
les monty notaire alors que vous avez
peut-être suivi que le préfet nous avait
dit qu'il était annulé ça aussi c'est
pas normal
a priori telle qu'à l'heure où je parle
je croise les doigts on est plutôt en
train de bien évoluer pour que cela ait
lieu
je me dis donc à ce micro il faut faire
campagne nous on n'arrête pas on est
tous les jours sur les marchés on est
aussi engagée peut-être vraiment parler
sur cette belle légiste a terminé
justement a permis sur l'initiative donc
tant pis je voulais vous parler de la
sécurité des régionales mais avant sur
les sur les législatives
quelles leçons tirez
2 du premier tour de dimanche dernier et
est ce que vous êtes très inquiet de
voir l'abstention record dans ce grand
des quatre circonscriptions environ
peut-être que le premier tour et c'est
le parti socialiste contre la france en
a jamais parlé sur les toits partiel qui
ont eu lieu l'une celle de paris n'en
tirer qu'un mari d'accord vous avez bien
alors oui l'abstention à 15% de
participation bon c'est extrêmement
c'est ça le phénomène majeur mais au
sein après de ceux qui sont allés voter
moi je me félicite du fait qu'il ya à
mon amie danielle simonnet qui tu vends
une dirigeante de premier plan de la
france en soliste qui est au second tour
qui progresse par rapport à la dernière
fois qui va se retrouver face à une
candidate socialiste bon là encore qui a
reçu d'ailleurs le soutien de la
république en marche c'est bon c'est
assez clair je pense que ceux qui ont à
coeur la il ya deux projets clairement
le le hall ont 10 mhz qui revient avec
cette candidate socialiste c'est la
dernière circonscription là de la
dernière députée parisienne mais ça peut
être intéressant que ce soit vous voyez
les communistes soutenir la candidate
sociale soit je pense que les électeurs
communistes se retrouveront dans la
candidat milan ac simonet l'ailier celle
qui est la plus proche et 1011 que
pensent les communistes ou dans les
luttes mais lui le communiqué du parti
communiste qui est celui des sections du
20e arrondissement il celui national qui
invite ses électeurs à se rassembler
derrière pour faire élire je cite les
candidats de gauche les mieux placés
dans les circonscriptions de gauche dans
l'intyamon dispensés danielle simonnet
mais je vais faire je vais le ne pas le
dire ça c'est une petite plaisanterie
mais je veux dire clairement et
j'arrêterai là parce que surtout moi je
veux pas polémiquer les communistes sont
libres leur décision - dans si c'était
un communiste face à une candidate
sociale il appellera à voter communiste
très clairement
voilà donc chacun après en tirera les
conséquences je n'aurais pas je n'aurai
aucune ambiguïté je serai très clair
pour moi le projet terminé maintenant
c'est une dynamique qu'il faut créer
daniel le fait ce soir il y aura jean
luc mélenchon qui sera dans le 20e
arrondissement à 17h20 pour soutient
danielle simonnet on sera là et moi
toute la semaine j'étais déjà allé on va
y aller elle peut gagner c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est honnêtement c'est
un événement politique c'est une
insoumise de plus à l'assemblée
nationale le fait qu'ils aient une
socialiste de plus pour s'abstenir sur
beaucoup de texte etc
on ne sent pas être quelque chose de
majeur donc les amis surtout au delà de
ce que font les uns et les autres il ya
15% de participation au premier tour il
faut que la participation augmente de
manière générale moi je suis un
républicain qui pensent que le souverain
c'est le peuple
il faut aller voter et je répète cher
oriane parce que vous le faites ici
régulièrement le 20 juin élections
régionales on a besoin de gens impliqués
vous on a besoin d'assesseurs moi je
veux pas que cette élection soit aussi à
minima c'est ça qui m'inquiète et
beaucoup d'appareils politiques se
félicite qu une faible participation
parce que leurs petits réseaux
permettent d'obtenir des scores moi je
suis pour que le peuple viennent voilà
est rappelons le 20 et 27 juin élections
régionales et vous avez raison on en
parle beaucoup dans cette émission on va
continuer à en parler d'ailleurs tout de
suite de ces régionales etc
départementale mais je vous remercie
d'abord à l'exception d'eads est revenue
[Musique]